يمكن تعريف الراحه على انها اي سلوك يهدف
الى زياده الرفاهيه الجسديه او العقليه
فيمكن ان تكون عن طريق النشاط البدني مثل
الخروج للمشي او الاسترخاء مثل اخذ عشر
دقائق للجلوس والتنفس بعمق
قد يكون من الصعب تحديد معنى الراحه لكن
الدكتوره
حددتها في سبعه انواع وهي الراحه
الابداعيه والعقليه والجسديه والاجتماعيه
والعاطفيه والحسيه والروحيه وسيحتاج الشخص
على الارجح الى القليل من جميع هذه
الانواع حتى يعمل بشكل جيد والاتباع قاعده
42% راحه في اليوم تقترح الدراسه تقسيم
يوم كما يلي ثماني ساعات من النوم 20 الى
30 دقيقه من محادثات تقليل التوتر مع شريك
الحياه او قريب او صديق 30 دقيقه من
النشاط البدني 30 دقيقه من الاهتمام
بالطعام فتره حره مدتها 30 دقيقه حسب
الاحتياجات
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات